so uh now let's shift to how it is
working inside
the trump administration with president
trump directly so you go from being in
the business world running your own
business to suddenly you're working for
donald trump who from the outside
appears to be uh an interesting
boss what is it like to work with uh
that's putting it mildly how is it
how is it to work with president trump
on a daily basis what is it
that people on the outside get right
about it and what is it that people on
the outside get wrong about
working with and for president trump so
i i think the best description
from an external point of view that i
saw after the last election was a woman
wrote
that the media took donald trump
literally but not seriously but the
voters took him seriously but not
literally
and you know what i understand about him
is first of all say it's been an
absolute you know thrill working with
him i think he's obviously a brilliant
person
um you know he can't have accomplished
everything that he's accomplished in his
life without being you know a brilliant
person and
you know i've also you know gone through
this experience with him of seeing him
you know adapt to politics and then also
adapt to being president and continue to
grow
uh and make decisions right and what
he's really done is is he's increased
the metabolism of
of government you know in a tremendous
way right he's very demanding as a boss
and during that you know the cream rises
and i'm not going to say a bad word but
that sinks you know along the way
uh but what he is able to do is um
is uh is is really pushed for results
and so uh what he finds is that he's
very uh
trusting of of of the different uh you
know
agency heads or people he's hiring to do
jobs and you know he likes to agree with
them on what
you know what the goal is and then he
gives them a fair amount of latitude
uh to try to you know accomplish it
unless it's something that he's you know
tremendously focused on then he'll have
very strong points of view on how to do
it but
you know for me working with him i i
find that you know it's um
it's very interesting to watch him work
you know other world leaders to watch
him work you know members of congress
he likes to keep people off balance i
think that's where he finds
his strategic advantage and i've seen
him again out maneuver some of
the toughest uh and smartest world
leaders that we deal with because again
he's trying to always fight for
america's interests
but he's the first president that truly
understands i think america
american power uh the power that we have
economically
and um i think a lot of politicians are
trained to stay away from uncertainty
they see uncertainty as an enemy because
the media jumps all over them
uh he's used uncertainty as a weapon and
i think he's used that to create
outcomes that you know many people
didn't think would be possible and then
just you know on a personal level i i
find that every day is different
you know you never know what issue he's
on you know he's not
uh a lot of people try to manage a boss
you know he's not a boss that's
manageable you know he likes to get his
information from
uh from a lot of different sources and i
think that that's a healthy thing
because again he doesn't want
you know a filtered point of view he'll
want to speak to uh
you know tons of people and that's i
think a very very good thing
um and then again he's very common sense
and he's not afraid to take on fights
you know sometimes we
you know wish he took on a few less
fights but the reality is is he views it
like he was given this
opportunity from the american people uh
to
to lead the greatest country in the
world and you know he's going to spend
every minute of every day
you know fighting uh to try to push
forward on the issues that he cares
about whether it's a small issue or a
big issue
he's going to be pushing forward so he's
very demanding i mean it's a
it's truly a 24 7 job i'll get calls
from him at one o'clock in the morning
i'll get calls at five o'clock in the
morning
um and uh you know he'll want to know
the latest on this and sometimes i'll
say how the you know why is he thinking
about this issue
at this moment in time but you know he's
a very prolific reader he's he's always
staying on top of the news
and and what's happening and so it's
it's quite funny and i'd say the one
final thing is that
um he's actually very funny too and and
so you know when you're with him he has
a great sense of humor and uh
and uh you know i find the media doesn't
do a good job they they
tend to lose their sense of humor when
it comes to him but you know he'll be
sarcastic or whole joke but he's got a
very good sense of irony
and uh and uh and it's never boring and
i i will just say
you know finally that you know i think
that you know i've been blessed to work
with some incredible people at the white
house if you look at the people who are
really
you know at the campaign and then now
have worked all the way through there's
you know a very core group of people who
uh really love the president understand
the president and who are
you know devoted to helping him see
through what he started
and i would say that that group's been
you know incredibly successful and
you know i guess you know i don't know
how politics was before i got here i
again i it was never something i focused
on as closely but
i guess there's maybe a new thing of
trying to vilify uh
the people you know around a principal
not just a principal now in politics but
you know these are all people who could
be making a lot more money working a lot
less seeing their families more
but they don't do that you know they
take the abuse they work for lower
salaries and they could be making
and they work 24 7 because they believe
that this country is worth fighting for
if you enjoyed this video be sure to hit
the thumbs up button and share it with
all of your friends